Luke here with the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel I'm up in the mountains of
Alaska and the weather is trying to kill
me I got hit with a serious winter
snowstorm in the middle of September and
I'm happy to seek shelter in a survival
cabin to stay warm I'm cold and I'm wet
but I'm having quite the adventure
[Music]
well I've got good news and I've got bad
news the bad news is that it's cold and
wet and it's probably going to dump snow
on me tonight the good news is I've got
the trail all to myself so since I'm all
by my lonesome I'm going to turn on my
tracking on my Garmin inreach mini so my
wife knows where I am
all right first mile
now I've got a really good chance of
seeing some tarmigan or Grouse on the
road I love to hunt and eat those but I
ended up not bringing my gun just
because it was a lot of extra weight you
know the Surefire way to see birds is to
not bring your gun
uh Trail is starting to get narrow and
Mucky
check these out
this is mountain ash so this is mountain
ash or Rhone never eaten these before
some people say that they're good some
people say they're poisonous best
information I can find that the flesh is
edible but the seeds will give you some
discomfort mountain ash is really common
in this part of Alaska and it's a berry
you can find pretty late in the season
this right here is a willow
in the wintertime Willow is the primary
food source for moose tarmigan and hairs
it also has some medicinal properties
the greenish yellow inner bark of a
willow has aspirin in it
it tastes just like biting into an
aspirin pill
but it's obviously not as potent as an
aspirin pill so you'd have to chew a lot
of it to get the same dose but it's a
pretty wretched way to get pain relief
oh look at this
that my friends is snow oh boy
winter is coming
all right two miles down I'm just barely
starting to get that aspirin taste out
of my mouth
mile number three
my pants are getting wet I can start to
feel it soak through right there I'm
breaking the main rule of Big Boy
survival don't wet your pants
look at that water that is so clear
gorgeous
there's mile number four
check out this Beaver Pond this is the
beaver Den it's hollow inside
and there's usually like a little hole
down in there where the beaver comes up
under water and then he can hang out
inside this right here is the Beavers
food pile these are all Willows that
he's not often stored in front of his
house for winter time when ice covers
the pond he'll go down underneath the
ice and grab food from underneath the
ice and bring it into his den see this
little slide right here
all right he scoots back and forth so
you can see this entire wall of mud that
was all made by a beaver that's the
beaver sorry about that gotta watch my
language I want to keep this family
friendly
seeing more and more snow slowly getting
an elevation
mile number five
it is so a watermelon Berry
it's rare to find watermelon berries in
the fall they're usually gone by the end
of the summer
man it's 33 degrees and raining out here
I don't understand why I'm not seeing
anybody else on this Trail
oh geez just hit the Six Mile mark
got some blueberries
there's a bunch of curl berries some of
them are kind of red it's been such a
cold wet year the berries aren't
ripening properly
they're not ripe yet it's too bad
because there's a ton of them
oh my fingers are getting numb I brought
a pair of gloves with me but I don't
want them getting soaked on my first day
I just did seven miles now for the hard
part we gotta climb that thing
whoo
well it's starting to properly snow on
me my hands are so cold right now
I need a little snack break
all right we just completed eight miles
this is where I got to be really careful
my muscles are tired I'm fatigued and
everything is slippery just gotta take
it nice and slow unfortunately the path
is getting covered up with snowing
that's not making my life easier
the snow is completely covered up The
Path
but that's okay I know where I'm going
just need to follow this little stream
the headwaters of the stream are in a
saddle that'll get me over this mountain
oh
my battery just died my hands are so
cold I had to use my teeth to get it out
it is getting a bit much I need to find
some shelter my hands get too cold I
can't light my stove or set up my tent
I'm gonna do all those real important
things
oh there's a tarm again right there
that's a rock Ptarmigan as opposed to a
willow Target The Rock Target can live
up here in the Rocky parts of the
mountains they're a little smaller and
they make a different sound
like there's a Target right there
I knew I should have brought the 22.
having to pick my way through these
Boulders has taken so much time
I gotta be careful I don't fall down
oh I am exhausted my limbs are numb it's
slick it's getting dark it's really easy
for me to take a bad fall here I've got
to be careful
oh I finally get to go downhill a little
bit
oh look at that
there's a cabin
oh how do I get down there I've never
been so glad to see a shelter it's just
in the nick of time
sun is gonna set here in less than an
hour slow it's fast fast and slow
ah that one hurt a little bit
oh he's got an outhouse
oh my goodness
how do you get inside
oh I'm so cold
oh I am
so cold so cold I had to use my teeth to
undo the buckle for my backpack
I need to get dry immediately
this is a mountaineering cabin it's a
shelter from the storms for people
exploring the mountains here in Alaska
it was built by volunteers from the
mountaineering Club of Alaska there's a
whole bunches of odds and ends
equipment
whole bunches of tools in there in here
got a little table and chairs
mountaineering books an amount poker
chips and decks of cards trivia Pursuit
little kitchen area
some pots and pans oh there's just a
little bit of fuel in there
oh that's a full can
don't pee in the outhouse
got it there's a little ladder here in
the loft
oh look at their little Library there a
little Loft to sleep in
nice
got some old mats and stuff
I am so cold I think I'm gonna bust out
my sleeping bag and get it set up in the
Loft hop inside for a little bit well
I'm glad I kept my gloves dry but I
think it's time to use them
I can't even get my fingers enough
oh
[Music]
I've got these adhesive body warmers
gonna use these
ah
well man I didn't think I was that cold
but I want to get in here I'm just
freezing
[Applause]
when I was packing for this trip I had a
nice little bag of hot chocolate and
herbal teas
is going to bring that along
and uh I think I forgot it because it's
not in my bag so I just got a little hot
water and honey in a cup and I'm gonna
drink that because I'm so cold
yep that's good enough
I found my bag of hot chocolate yay
hello
oh my bag is soaked see how bad it is
oh geez
oh yeah my bag is pretty wet
I hate the rain
hot water bottles in here
okay
thank you
foreign
got some stretchy pants on got these
down booties
they're wonderful I feel like I'm
starting to not die
I'm wearing every bit of dry clothing
that I have and I've got two water
bottles in here and I'm snuggled up in
my sleeping bag
I'm super hungry and I want to cook some
dinner but I'm just going to sit in this
bag until I feel warm
once my body feels nice and warm then
I'll go make dinner
gonna eat a little snack while I sit
here and warm up I got some smoked
alligator gar from our trip to Louisiana
oh
you got some dates
well it took a while but I'm feeling
warm again my base layers and underwear
are still pretty wet but
it's warm that's a lot better
but I think I need to make some dinner
it is getting really late oh it is cold
in here
foreign
we're going to make some quesadillas oh
it feels so much better with your
fingers work
pork chili verde we're gonna stuff
inside
okay
smell you
I forgot to bring a plate but I found
this one
ah dang it just drop my knife and busted
the tip off it
wow I really like this knife this is
stuck together
oh
that's good
got a little can of salsa here
oh
come on that's good
roast a little marshmallow here
got a little chocolate sauce
[Music]
oh oh that hits the spot
it's gonna get well below freezing
tonight
I ate about nine and a half miles today
and climbed 3 600 feet in elevation so
we are we are way up in the mountains
whoa my pole prop in the door closed so
the wind doesn't open it
but look at that there is a proper pile
of snow out there we got close to a foot
on the ground and we could get a lot
more snow tonight
[Music]
we're gonna reheat this bottle too
I'm going to bed with pipe and hot
bottles
I'll tell you what I wouldn't mind a
little bit of hot chocolate too
with marshmallow
actually seems to be drying me out
pretty good I feel a low drier just
since I put this hot water bottle under
my clothes mint hot chocolate that is
good stuff
oh that was good I got my clothes hung
up and I'm hoping they'll dry a little
bit before tomorrow morning now I'm not
holding out a lot of hope I think I'm
gonna go hop into bed no sense and run
around here my stretchy pants
oh I can't tell you how much I've warmed
up just by being dryer
oh
and having a little food in me doesn't
hurt either
all right it's late and I'm exhausted
I'm gonna see you guys in the morning
oh good morning I didn't sleep
particularly well last night but I was
warm ended up having to take my jacket
off it got too hot something I didn't
think it was possible when I went to bed
ah
all right
you know I wouldn't call that dry but
that's not dripping wet oh they're so
cold oh I'm terrified about putting
those back on I think there's a shutter
on that window if I go outside I can
open it up
look at this Valley
oh
that's where we came down last night
we've got this board all covered in
Nails that's to keep Bears out
Bears get real curious
man I I really need to use the bathroom
I think I better go check out the
outhouse
many of these cabins are maintained by
the mountaineering Club of Alaska they
don't require any reservations or fees
they just ask that you'd be a
news-paying member or if you get stuck
in the weather and it's an emergency
you're more than welcome to use them too
but the first come first serve and they
can be quite popular in the summertime
when the weather's good if you guys want
to learn more about these cabins or
donate to the mountaineering Club of
Alaska I'll put a link in the video
description below
let's see if we got a little more
sunlight in here
that's a little nicer
we can admire that view a little bit now
[Applause]
all right I got some steel cut oats here
I'm gonna make some good oatmeal
oh
alrighty
good hearty oatmeal with butter and
brown sugar it's hard to beat
oh it feels good to have hot food to me
build up another hot water bottle
this one is going to go to try to dry
out my pants
well darn it I think that's actually
working
oh
you know it's nice to just sit here and
not be wet and cold
oh I'm really trying to think hard about
what to do next originally I was
planning on spending three days hiking
through these mountains and I was gonna
go to the crash site of a B-29 bomber
last summer I did a two-day hike to that
crash site and it was really cool and
I've wanted to go back ever since but to
get there you've got to go over two
glaciers and around this mountain and
there's a big problem let me show you
if I want to go to the bomber crash site
I've got to climb two and a half
thousand vertical feet up over that
saddle and there's a foot of ice and
snow on those rocks and it's been
snowing on and off all morning so
there's a really good chance I could get
caught in another snowstorm the
weather's definitely been a lot worse
than I anticipated on this trip
man I was so cold yesterday I really
feel like I pressed my luck a little bit
more than I like to do
and I'm thinking I just need to head
back home and I'm about 80 the way
through my fuel I have just barely
enough fuel to cook dinner tonight that
means no hot water bottles no hot drinks
you know and that's going to be really
rough if I'm wet again so I'm thinking
the smart move is to hike the nine and a
half miles back through the snow and if
you guys want to see the crash site and
those other survival Huts I'll put a
link to my video from last summer in the
video description below but I think I
need to start packing up and getting my
gear ready
thank you
you know hot sports drink ain't bad
pants are soaking wet pretty much
everywhere except for where the bottles
were
[Applause]
it's been a fun but challenging trip so
far but I think it's time to call it
let's you gotta lock this place up
uh make sure we put my snow Gators on
these Burton snow pants have built-in
snow Gators I'd have two pounds of snow
in each shoe if it wasn't for those snow
Gators
you know this place is beautiful when
it's not trying to kill you
there's some Ptarmigan tracks right
there must be pretty fresh because it
was snowing this morning
look at this
it's a snow spider
now I know spiders can crawl into my
mouth while I'm sleeping in a snow cave
there's something to be afraid of in the
wintertime
I found my trail this is the stream I
was following yesterday
oh but look at that the sun's come out
and it is gorgeous
look at this
just makes you feel tiny doesn't it that
sun coming off the snow is Bright Now
that I pulled my sunglasses out I've
jinxed it it's gonna snow on me any
minute now
foreign
it's starting to rain properly I'm glad
I got off that mountain I bet it's
snowing like the devil up there
three miles to go
there you go one mile if I hurry up I
might make it to my car before my
underwear gets wet yay
well keeping with the pattern of this
trip I am soaking wet and freezing cold
but I made it back to the car and I have
feel pretty good about my decision to
call in early but hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video if you want to see
more videos from the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel make sure to click
subscribe I'll see you guys next video
If you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button and you'll get notifications
thanks for watching